pas fini la tour brune la nouvelle
Maison de Radio-Canada se dévoile enfin
à son public par centaines il déambulent
dans l'atrium
ils sont curieux de comprendre l'envers
du décor
on a écouté le début des chefs alors
voir le
où ça s'est tourné c'était vraiment
intéressant
après la politique c'est le journaliste
de guerre la lourdeur elle vient
vraiment de la plaque à l'intérieur la
plaque de métal l'animatrice est
ancienne correspondante Céline Galipeau
explique l'équipement nécessaire en
terrain hostile
en étage le public visite des régies des
studios pour mieux comprendre le travail
des journalistes
sont vraiment
des meilleurs qu'est-ce qu'ils ont la
visite est à guichet fermée c'est plus
de 5000 personnes qui visiteront la
nouvelle maison d'ici dimanche
après-midi mais devant l'engouement
Radio-Canada a ajouté 500 nouvelles
places
plusieurs personnalités de Radio-Canada
sont présentes pour accompagner les
visiteurs je la découvre en même temps
que tout le monde fait que c'est très le
fun parce que les gens ont beaucoup de
questions à poser une belle curiosité on
est fière de notre culture puis il faut
il faut se défendre comme tellement des
grosses machines comme Netflix tout seul
que je sais pas un lieu comme ça ça fait
comme non non on résiste attention on
est là vous pouvez me suivre cette
ouverture des portes n'est que le début
pour Radio-Canada à partir du 8 octobre
il sera possible de visiter gratuitement
la fin de semaine ce réservation
ici Marie-José paquet au Canada Montréal